the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free to make a donation or to view
additional materials from hundreds of
MIT courses visit MIT opencourseware at
ocw.mit.edu
our special guest lectures
and
hi music matters it really does are you
a musician yep we put I think the snare
drum the bass drum tambourine pretty
much all but your eyes times like that's
really cool the way it's going to work
give you five minutes at each station
with your consultants and during the
five minutes go ahead and as for the
mitc going to introduce yourself and
tell them what you study maybe what here
you are what you're interested in and
then if you feel comfortable showing
them the video pitch that you made last
night we have this to you with gracious
just know that that's out of our control
we're really sorry that they're doing
some construction over there and it's
been easy sorry so go ahead and show
them your pitch if you're comfortable
with it
tell them your idea and then workshop
some of the backup ideas that you
thought about last night and the
Cummings middle school students know
exactly what criteria is you're looking
for writing to you the river except that
we gave you a van at the end of the five
minutes I have the MIT students rotate
so Nathan you'll go to the back
hollyoaks here everyone just shift that
way that make sense we'll try it out for
the first month if anyone has any
questions you can always come talk to
one of the instructors okay so does
anyone have any questions about how this
is going to work before we get started
or what your job is and then you have a
question about that either
your job it's a very important job
everyone knows what to do so I will go
ahead and start the timer for the first
five minutes and if at any point you
have a question about what you're doing
or find one of us have fun yeah just
show introduction I study computer
science or anyone knowing what is kinda
like programming kind of time like oh
and so the kind of stuff like to do is
like I make water from the games so this
kinda like / don't like you know so you
you kinda like fruit ninja or a few
ninja but accept pets know it today it
slashes no way it's kind of like the
same but this time you get a lot of
combos Oh / the rate one can lose time
just point and you eventually lose the
game it's kind of like the kind things I
do you know yeah I mean it's kind of
like Britain job but accept that don't
slap the rates no fixin it's okay if
there's no fix for all oh the blue ones
give you these mega explosions and they
can play here yeah so I have this idea
like it's just without programming how
can you make copy the girl that's kind
of like what i was thinking on off my
dear what do you think of that do you
have like things you like when you clean
your floors you're playing games a lot
on your face
definite here what's your favorite I
like a lot of them plus social media ah
socially near that kind of I really have
a favorite oh I play madden bowling
clash of cultures I'm a question
Atlantis totally addicted yeah so it'd
probably be about right how can you come
up ideas the main game to test honestly
the people who is trying to meet game I
probably not as smart as anyone out
there because you play the games you
know what people like to play it's not
something me is it's you you you know
what likes place say people like you
could make the games that people think
people that owe you justify a little bit
green all right yeah ok well just just
another curious cat questions do you
know what a heck goes no oh hacker yeah
Hector oh yeah some of those like invade
them oh the fire wall thingy here Oh
security get those very far yeah yeah
would you like would you wanna know what
what what's a hacker you do know okay
then that's descriptive about a curious
question everyone knows Google yeah but
what do they do search engine okay yeah
so and then what what does that what
does that make a better place how are
they like so important in our lives oh
cuz we like we do I remember
oh okay helpful yeah okay you can also
just curious do you because i'm actually
not from us and we perform with little
country in asia singapore yeah so just
curious do I study programming as your
age not any kinds of not like okay me
neither i've never started with my
auntie I came to university yeah so yeah
so what do you think program is like
what do you think your grandma's degree
they'll be no games cones if you were to
be like cures of a lot of programming or
what can he do what what would interest
games with it
I pretty much play games I can't go
online cuz it's an iphone I don't have a
nice so out of the random ideas are true
at which one like would you be
interested in like a possible video
football games yeah thnkx something to
do it what's the like the interesting
you have in your mind like it always
next you about computers again life's
too slow just like even when you have
Wi-Fi in range and you're like near the
routers I think it's always really slow
ok I am I phone you can't forget but I'm
in my car I can't play are you getting
to know myself Oh feel like my games at
your feet intimate yeah okay I like
boyfriends
okay we should have built in Wi-Fi okay
what about maybe all you know pics are
you like your movies yeah i love the
incredibles by those really old but I
still love it maybe this is it yeah and
have you ever wonder like how they do it
it kind of looks different from like
they're normal yeah so they actually use
some computer software do it it's called
3d animation like three-dimensional is
that interesting yeah I would be
interested yeah like how do you draw but
on the other i do they have to draw a
little picture of every movement ah
that's the key it's no it's actually the
answer's no it's pretty cool right what
they do is like kind of like they make a
teddy bear in the computer like some
kind of like 3d image of it and they put
bones in like like just like how you put
on to humans but he was programming you
put by logical bones and then you can
shift the bones and you're like puppets
you know yeah is it this kind of like
what didn't work okay so we should one
of the ideas or it's like like the last
one yeah last one of all right thank you
guys you're so amazing okay
to lenox earrings
I'm Nathan I study
something that's a mix of a cafe in
geology yeah I'm a second year I
have two ideas it looks like my main
idea has been scrapped at this point but
i'll still mention to you in case one of
you fervently interested in it which is
i was interested in possibly doing
something on how and why 313 decomposes
but I guess my backup idea was a bit
more interesting to those people which
is how you can tell if there's a magma
lava under a surface like and how you
can detect and map it and then you might
be able to say oh is this place in visco
having some sort of eruption at some
point we're not have to work on the hook
oh no do you think it is more interested
oh it was the first one yeah I'm heron
why food rots and decomposers I would
probably do the lava stuff yeah it's
like
yeah save lives yeah I know exactly what
to say about that what would you be
expecting if you wanted to watch a video
about like that wouldn't want to be
diving around okay hemisphere
and has set a screen like the layers and
then having like a fall through like you
said it's a house action good check if
there's lava under Sir probably heavenly
a place that already does out love on
the surface and like showing the magma
chamber it sounds like you guys already
done that unit on volcanoes you is there
any like any question you have that you
still have that you might want to answer
like
so he's like that
this part of the unit I've seen their
videos in volcanoes erupting at night
was pretty
I'd probably call a question I have
there's some volcanoes that usually
they're big but they have smaller
options and then they do like a big one
and then there's other volcanoes out to
have just huge eruptions every thousand
out why would some volcanoes have big
eruptions and somehow small small and
then a big alright so here's what I'd
say the positon have small eruptions
it's actually based a lot on what the
makeup of the reef the lava from the
volcano is I don't know if you to be
probably on the 15 and acidic and
anesthetic volcanoes and basically
glasses made something called silica
silicon said okay it's an element and
volcanoes that have a lot more silica in
it they tend to be a little less dense
and wanted to have lower content are a
lot heavier the magma and so as you
might expect the ones that are heavier
when they erupted it doesn't just shoot
out everywhere just kind of like bubbles
over the side and it's like more viscous
and it flows
slowly and so those ones often would be
the ones like the big mountain is that
like kind of like spread out this way a
lot that's feel like it she'll love it
yeah visit your volcanoes and so the
lava type causes it to have a lot more
smaller eruptions because it takes a lot
of build up a pressure if you want to
have a big ol option for that whereas we
have a higher silica content when things
that weighs less it's going to explode
more and it's going to have more violent
eruptions and those other factors as
well like water content and that what
depth of the magma chamber underneath
the volcanoes
if you don't have an i believe are you
yes that volcano is our door map for a
longer period when they erupted would
they have a violent eruptions then
what's that a doormat shorter um I can't
actually answer that question I know
like what causes both hands to go in
more German what make them might make
them not going bike Emily say if that
effect okay one thing about mad that you
have really enjoyed or really hate it or
two things so we'll start love to write
so name favorite subject and thinks
about map that you have really loved or
really hated okay my name is Brian
chapters
Jim and I
man
okay actually there is this it's a kind
of new direction but a lot of people are
actually studying the math scores so
they go out and do you really weird
things with sports like throwing
basketballs at like places where you
should shoot an arrow kind of thing and
they do Matthew them so that's kind of a
connection gym and math getting closer
together my name is Matt I like math
here that brine and most of their thing
that I've said some things that you
really enjoyed or hated about me I am
joy solving variables and equations and
graphing things that's good you're ready
for high school my name is my name is
John histories
hi guys
really into like that just like me I
belong
okay what you know what a bad the idea
I've never heard anybody say I like the
idea of fraction so that's really
interesting to me I think just like by
this table thousands
now really wacky things that
mathematicians do later on is that they
don't just break the table into a
thousand pieces that's like too easy
they break it into an infinite number of
pieces and then they see what they can
do with that and kind of related to that
mathematicians have proof but you can
take a ball as you know just volume 1 1
gallon oh and you can cut it in such a
way that you can make 2 1 gallon goes so
you can make two out of one using math
so that's a similar you like math now
boys I mean if you think about it math
people do really cool things like there
was a study once where they analyzed the
language of King George and Kanye West
and they compare them and this is like
an actual study like they put time into
it glad about that was pretty cool but
um anyway that's not what my pitches are
down and I'll just kind of sit real
quick not going to show the video
because the sound is terrible what I
want to talk about in my video is just
the question of is math real and true
because what up mathematicians learned
in the 20th century there was a young
man named Kirk colonel who proved that
you can never prove math is true or not
so the arithmetic we learned in school
like we think it's true because it's
worked but it may not be
there's no way to say for sure wait is
Kurt Colonel the guy who made kentucky
fried chicken no it's Kurt girdle I mean
I think would be really cool if you did
math in Kentucky Fried Chicken lifestyle
be the best her family guy and he was
like he went to Kentucky to get chicken
he's like is like whatever his name is
Sam like what you said I'd like like
nope instead it was like you have to
look and say no did any mathematicians
open fast food chains it's probably an
interesting question don't thing
anyone's ass kid before but that's okay
any thoughts on the idea just I'll get a
thumbs up thumbs down or thumbs middle
I'll her happy thanks guys I was nice
meeting you and enjoy playing more like
a hama minute your workout time I think
I think you want to get away from
instruction and more of like concept
right so see if you can think of a
little narrower focus than these big big
big concepts and that might help you
with your next girl so like you guys
like that's like some of them are frozen
like the robot suit yeah yeah so what
they're doing so we're teaching them you
need to rotate know you're okay what
we're doing is we're here scientists and
we're teaching them how to make have you
ever looked on full videos like have you
seen charlie the unicorn or you've seen
easy travel having a boy or maybe you've
seen the was it right I used to work
with kids your age and they loved that
one I was about this little snail Marcel
the show have you seen that one now well
you see these little YouTube videos and
everyone's like let's who you want to
watch that too I wonder one
which one is the 21 okay that's 21
evidence everybody really that is that
the it one you have to watch 21 it's
like it's like a vine it's a make a
youtube video or there's a s J's chosen
I YouTube God ASDF he's about to like
stick secure right so if you guys see
them and then you're like a friend
you've got to see this too and then
you're like you get everyone to watch it
right we're trying to make it was really
cool short videos about science topics
right and so we're gonna make them free
so that anyway so that it also teaches
people something while what's also cool
on fun right okay and so he's trying to
figure out is like what in his world of
computer science would be like cool
enough that you'd be like hey friend you
got to check this out it's really
awesome I think the hacker wanna would
be done is other people are to
understand like how someone hacked your
account yeah but they're gonna want to
spend want kids to have people well
that's it here right you don't want to
end up giving kids instructions on how
to hack because I don't think the
government or anyone else would probably
like that but that's a fear is making
sure that we're not actually giving
instructional videos on how to destroy
other people's credit cards sir tak 8am
normal running yeah protecting your how
to protect your right like yourself like
make sure your money safe or something
like that with means like how to type
stuff Packers how to protect yourself as
instead of like just drawing someone
else's somewhere yeah it was a nice to
see you so unless their wallet and
they had their credit card in there and
it can access to the bank is that the
person if someone found it in the
question access don't do they end up
hearing on the money sometimes and
that's why credit cards are really good
at beach you know anything about this in
your worker Nome pretty cuts credit card
it's like protecting credit card
identity and all that but don't they
have like your pictures and things
really know it's like you but online you
it's really easy to I use another
presence credit card you know order yeah
yeah it's cold I get called off and from
my bank saying did you make this
purchase or did someone else but that's
an interesting thing for people who do a
lot of shopping online yeah how do you
protect yourself and everybody else
should get money would you do that back
or no that's why if you catch it quickly
with your bank sometimes they can like
can quickly stop it before it ends up
get in turn to you but got an
interesting ideas how do you how do you
if you're buying stuff on this on the
internet like what's actually happening
to protect yourself glitter some like
someone like like if they did it did
like catch the person and the
personality you said the money and that
you can't like return it that did the
thing kind of giving like for money did
you ever wonder what happens when you
type in the credit card number and like
how the money actually gets where it
needs to go of it check them down like
have you ever wondered about how about
happiness no not really you just care
about getting it HM makes some money or
do they put ahead use do they just put
the money in there there's a whole every
country is different but at least here
there's a central office that makes
money and then they just distribute it
in two different places daddy cam
doesn't make the money
good question but interesting things do
you think about is sort of what within
these topics more specifically because
the hacking is a cool topic but you're
right it's a dangerous one and we'd want
to make sure we have the right angle so
that we're not accidentally giving sixth
graders the tools to be able to hack
into whatever account right that would
be scary anyway you're not being a good
fun the goo could be right how does
Google actually work how does it find
your result like if you want to learn
how is the birth of stripes how does it
actually give you an answer how does
like filming spread like a virus that's
a cool idea to like something to think
about keep thinking here on it good good
good vardis and you are enamor hi Emma I
know Jana no it's a really cool new spam
yeah thank you and gianna jams so we're
gonna have to move a little Coolidge's
got two teams to talk about so hard um
okay introduction first um I'm a first
year here at MIT I like to study math
physics and education I said it's too
much and I'm gonna just push the idea
right away normally I would ask you guys
what you like that the question that I
would like to discuss in the video is
whether math is actually being true and
the thing is that mathematicians have
proved that they can never prove that so
we can never know for sure if math is
true even arithmetic you know it's
worked for us so well you know too much
there's always for it seems but that may
not be so I guess that's kind of the
question I wanted to address and out of
that it also comes you know can machines
be smarter than humans and you know
being robots overtake the world so just
things like that so any socks which one
is so those were three topics right i'm
so that was one top one to happen like
just like all those questions kind of
come out of that those are big question
businesses what do you guys respond do
you think any of those ideas that she
meant sir are things that you would be
like hey friend this is really cool you
got to check out this video which one
the robot thing would robots take over
the world no really didn't I like the
one that it's like is it like choosing I
was like like far as far like eight is
that true so I'll tell you secret even
though we cannot tell that math is true
that's sad that also means that robots
cannot overtake the world it's not my
answer changing it to math the math one
but you'll get to the math one through
the robots well yeah right so you could
did you have any other ideas or was this
like the big idea those are payments so
you think that if she talks about the
idea of good robots overtake the world
and through that she answer some of the
questions about math beings who were not
true that would be really cool yes guy
welcome to take over the world you don't
think so big because
hey how about that you grow up as the
face of that thing I'm even smash them
and they wrinkle I try to scratch shoes
ha ha eventually we'll be smart because
that's kind of what a mathematician page
is that a machine can never be as smart
as a human or do as many things that we
can do is a good robots take over the
world idea with all this other stuff
connected to it I think that's a cool
idea do you know I'm show lab rats well
there was like these three humans who
are like also like a robot thing and
they have like all kinds of powers and
because there's this guy that wanted to
make them evil and like take over the
world not Disney chances you see and it
looks like this person stole that I'm
gonna make them between here's but can't
what it's like someone that mental robot
gives them up and says how early yeah
that's what you're saying that robust
gonna be really honest smart not as much
so I guess eventually we'll win the bar
to decide to break down on this I want
to make sure andrea get some time so
let's hear your ideas so that's
competition I'll be getting something
keep going okay so um I already know the
answer for you are you gonna have to
have braces something dunno no no no
what they call the Cohanim know kind of
it'll don't so would it how long have
you had your braces beginning your 5th
grade 1 s so you betta my wife yeah I
don't even know if I'm want braces
because can't you gum or yours back
nearest no i don't i do so you carry us
about like what they do to your teeth
looks like I'm straight I guess what do
you know how do you know how to do that
yeah they put them for same time
together that made him saying I'd like
to team up here to put it down yeah lets
you keep the flips I have a palate
expander to which I fell han sido issues
you everything talk like like like that
tough for a while it's like why did my
jaw that's key and everybody kind of her
you know one person what was it I'm
sorry I missed it what was your idea I'm
to talk about braces basically what
they're doing to your to me oh that's
cool I think bad fairies also are they
bad for your teeth that's a good
question why don't want our backs what
is your going like a branch so what
happens with stuff gets oh I just I just
got my braces off in October you my dad
has taught me to get them changed every
month it's been a very monthlies yeah so
what's actually going on with your
braces that's a cool very aged relevant
topic but instead of getting braces
can't you get that like plastic the
other minor ass yeah do not do a tater I
have to wear return I know one of my
friends who had them who likes still
wears
I'd like weird every day if you don't
worry night at cricketing every yet
favorite I am safe of that actually we
arrested your light if you don't wear
your retainer your teeth yeah you're
going to a b-school you have to i prey
on the rest of ya wear retainers they
give kids braces so young now like you
can be in third grade and have braces
murmurs when I was a kid you didn't get
them until like high school great yeah I
mean did it I I've seen lots of little
kids with braces and you're like you
Keith are so little yeah something you
have to wear retainers every effort of
your life for a while what about the
boost ahead here the headgear oh just
that I chat that's so just talking last
long it looks like here Charlie yeah
yeah
it makes you talk to we're actually
really would you do what you like I
heard some amazing conversations and you
sixth graders asked fantastic questions
what we're just wrapping up I love you
come from a couple groups of students
disappears what were some of the best
ideas that you heard all day that you're
like I can't wait for this video to its
mouth I really want to watch it and you
can hear any like ideas you're really
excited up yeah the Navy one what about
it which what would it he knows Tokyo's
interesting the idea of watching things
blow up and setting to you yes what else
I like the idea what the world was like
we were talking like
play what they run around with it so I
like just need to you're excited about
learning more about robots and how we
work yeah anyone else Chiana yeah pick
your best Island favors the abrasives
understanding what braces to your teeth
and how they work that's cool because
you've got races that that would be
interesting someone said like something
about volcano the volcanoes
understanding if there's a volcano
underneath our house that was in floyd
it is there lava under my house right
yes ne6 graters anything advice to RMIT
students before they take your good
feedback and turn them into videos
anything you want to make sure that they
know to do or not to do as they take
your good ideas and over the next month
develop them into actual
you like picture ideas instead of
talking to them like show examples i'm
going to memorizes that's what still we
talked about that MIT students up today
of showing challenge i'm sure you guys
talk about your writing a lot right
showing some time cool don't ask you
question the optimal video
questions
computing asking the audience yeah I
said I'm saying like
if you just say one thing
so acting your audience too many facets
of annoying yeah you person you
original so try to have a new idea
try and make some jokes all you do it so
your audience laughs at it and that's
like they understand what
awesome last one don't usually consist
Lamont enrich pitch awesome to change
their voice around make it more interest
in MIT students and curious from you
what was valuable that you got from the
5th graders today to give them some
feedback about this experience did
anyone get good feedback yeah well i
found that financial realize this is
that having robot stone
Industries is way more fun than showing
robots that hi to learn that might taste
a different of that law and volcanoes a
lot more interesting that through
decomposing he wanted to show food
rotting and everyone thought that was
not as fun as volcanoes exploding um any
other thing from the MIT students that
you found it helpful yeah how its kind
of but I know it was some like to know
how much people like situated know about
some of the really complicated subjects
that were even learning awesome a lot we
have to be a conversation about sticking
and floating and how to both even work
it was awesome what you guys knew well
we can't think our idea max to the light
and the video that you guys think of you
last month they're almost finished very
with them
any directions from teachers before they
leave the room
nope just take one lon single line so i
can count before you leave the building
and then i'll count you on the bus again
never again of the things that have to
thank you hey thank you so much